[Music]
foreign
the best way to understand the metaverse
is to experience it yourself experience
it yourself experience it yourself
[Music]
yeah I definitely don't feel very well
right now
by now I'm sure you've heard of
Facebook's grand plan for the metaverse
Zuckerberg believes that the metaverse
is the future of a virtual school work
communication gaming social media and
basically anything else you can think of
and he's so confident in this Vision
that he went as far as changing the
entire company's name from Facebook to
meta I am proud to announce that
starting today our company is now meta
some think that Zuckerberg has lost his
mind for pursuing this dead end so
viciously While others feel that
Zuckerberg is leading forward the VR
Revolution regardless of which side you
stand on one thing that we can all agree
on is that the metaverse has thus far
been an extraordinarily expensive over
the last few years meta has invested
over 10 billion dollars into metaverse
every single year and this trend is
expected to carry on for several years
with the total budget of 100 billion
dollars but despite Zuckerberg's
willingness to go all in and bet big and
it doesn't seem like meta has been able
to produce any Real Results I mean this
right here is the end result of spending
tens of billions on R D as many have
pointed out it doesn't look all that
much better than me from 2006 or even
Minecraft and those games aren't even
trying to be realistic while meta is
literally trying to create a virtual
reality now you might be thinking that
the ludicrous cost can be explained by
the fact that meta is having to develop
a bunch of new technology but here's the
thing GTA 5 which looks like this only
cost 265 million to make and this game
is now nearly 10 years old meanwhile
Apple's entire r d cost between 2002 and
2007 was only 3.4 billion heck even the
self-driving industry as a whole is only
estimated to have invested 100 billion
since 2010. in other words the metaverse
is expected to cost 33 times the cost of
the original iPhone and the entirety of
the self-driving investment thus far to
make things worse it doesn't seem like
anyone even wants to use the DECA
billion dollar products coming out of
beta this one metaverse feature which
cost 1.2 billion for example has a mere
38 active users so here's the baffling
economics of the metaverse
foreign
one of the main reasons that the
economics of the metaverse has become so
bloated it is because meta itself has
become a bloated company since 2018
alone meta has grown their employee
account from 35 000 to 72 000 and much
of this hiring has to do with metaverse
development not only did meta hire tens
of thousands of people over the past few
years but they hired them at the
absolute highest costs they were
offering principal software engineers at
1.82 million dollars senior directors at
3.14 million dollars and even recruiters
up to 270 thousand dollars theoretically
this was supposed to help them hire the
best talent but there's one fundamental
flaw with this approach just because you
pay the highest salary does not mean
that you'll actually attract the best
talent while the best talent it does
indeed want to be paid well they care
much more about the work that they're
doing it and they're trying to create
real world impact and to put it bluntly
the top talent simply does not give a
crap about meta or the metaverse and
this isn't speculation it's actually a
verifiable trend you see it before
metastop got destroyed and they had to
do hiring freezes and the layoffs they
were aggressively recruiting but with
little success despite literally
offering a 100th percentile salaries
Mata was struggling to get even 50 of
Engineers to accept their job offers
that itself is a pretty shocking fact
but I'd argued that this is even worse
than it appears on the surface and it's
more than likely that the 50 who did
accept the job offers were swayed by the
money or Prestige as opposed to the job
itself now there's nothing wrong with
this as these guys were just looking out
for themselves but it does leave meta
with quite a conundrum it's a simple
fact that people who do a job for money
are less productive than those who do it
with a passion the recent meta offered
so much was to ideally attract the
latter but it looks looks like they
ended up paying top of the market
salaries and attracting the former
anyway and this brings us to the much
larger problem within meta as a whole it
seems that Zuckerberg has this mindset
that money and the brute force can solve
any issue but he's finding out the hard
way that that's not true just because
you spend a 500 million on a project
that should only cost 300 million does
not mean that the project will be
completed faster better or with greater
appeal in fact it's likely to create
even more inefficiencies as employees
won't have to be under a game to finish
the project this is one of the main
reasons that we saw so many daily life
Tech talks about Facebook employees
doing absolute Jack normal companies
would just go ahead and fire these
individuals but even that Facebook was
already struggling to meet their hiring
goals the last thing they wanted to do
was let go of their existing staff until
recent times of course given the
recession meta has shifted most of their
focus to running a title ship than
trying to to get more people on board
but this is nonetheless one of the main
reasons that metaverse projects are
coming out with ridiculous price tags
aside from being bloated another massive
hurdle that meta has been tackling with
is technological shortcomings or more
accurately self-imposed shortcomings if
you're familiar with traditional VR
offerings you know that the Vira headset
is usually just a display and the input
device it's not a rendering device the
rendering endographical work is usually
offloaded to a powerful gaming PC so if
you wanted the game in VR you not only
needed an expensive headset but an even
more expensive gaming PC this of course
made the technology virtually
inaccessible to the general public but
this was simply the reality of
translating AAA games to VR at least
somewhat respectively meta however
decided to completely throw this out the
window and try to render everything on
board the headset itself I mean they did
have good intentions as this was
supposed to make VR more affordable and
accessible given that you only needed
the headset but this also drove meta's
focus in the wrong direction instead of
spending their tens of billions on game
development software animations and the
UI they spent much of it on optimizing
and shrinking down hardware and even
then they had to make major sacrifices
when it comes to computational power
which is not that surprising there's a
reason that gaming PCs are so big it's
not just to make them look cool with RGB
and liquid cooling Loops it's because
you need that much space to optimally
fit and sufficiently equal Advanced Tech
we should also note that the most
powerful chips don't get their power
from being more efficient than smaller
chips they often get their power from
Simply being bigger So Meta was actively
trying to work against all of this they
were trying to get the headset and
controllers to keep track of 10 cameras
through Optical recognition on these
cameras keep track of physical body
movement account for inputs from their
controllers render appropriate game
content and display
1920x1800 resolution content for each
high at 90 alerts all while trying to
maintain respectable battery life and
not overheat with so many technological
challenges I don't think that you'd be
surprised here that the vast majority of
medicine investment has gone towards
simply making the technology functional
as opposed to making the software and
the graphics good many would argue that
this is the completely wrong approach
and I'd have to agree instead of
targeting the existing VR Market by
creating unreal graphics and experiences
that would blow people's minds they
decided to spend all their effort trying
to Port a high-end gaming PC into a
headset and while I'm sure that was
extremely challenging to do it didn't
really help the metaverse live up to the
hype of its massive price tax speaking
of price tags meta was also attempting
to offer all of this for fifteen hundred
dollars which while expensive is nowhere
near enough to make up for their
development and production expenses for
perspective you know all those fancy
games that people compare to the
metaverse well all those games are run
on the most advanced consumer gpus like
the 4080 which cost 1200 by itself So
Meta is losing money on both ends when
it comes to the metaverse
[Music]
while all of meta's moves may be
confusing from a consumer standpoint it
makes a lot more sense from an
Enterprise perspective the reason that
they want the headsets to be independent
is so that they can tell it to companies
as an alternative video conferencing
solution this way companies will only
have to buy the headset not the headset
and the computer this is also the reason
that meta is spending so much money on
trying to perfect facial expression
recognition it's supposed to help with
video conferencing but there's one fatal
flaw with this entire pitch who's to say
that companies are even interested in
purchasing this technology companies
purchase things for their employees for
one reason and one reason only to
improve productivity the main things
that companies purchase for employees
are computers and cell phones and these
make employees immeasurably more
productive but the value of this over
Zoom or teams is questionable to say the
least not to mention the massive
difference in price long term their
pitch would probably be that companies
can avoid flying directors and
Executives around the world by
leveraging the metaverse but here's the
thing companies that don't send
Executives around the world because of
virtual meetings aren't Advanced enough
they send them around the world to make
Impressions close deals and make clients
feel valued for example let's say your
Oracle and that you have an upcoming
meeting with Google one of your VPS can
meet with the Google over Zoom just fine
but it makes a way stronger impression
if you send a VP to meet with the
Shanghai Google office in person and
when we're talking about multi-billion
Dollar Deals it's more than worth it for
Oracle to fly the VP to Shanghai a
metaverse meeting would simply not be a
good substitute regardless of how good
it gets so as much as Zuckerberg wants
the metaverse to be a replacement for
in-person meetings and it's more than
likely just going to be a replacement
for Zoom meetings which isn't
necessarily A Bad Thing there could be
value there for many companies but given
the slow pace of corporate adoption and
the state of the metaverse today that's
likely several years in the future if
not decades in fact matter themselves
are struggling to get their own internal
employees to use the technology and they
basically have unlimited free access to
it so it seems like the metaverse is yet
to even be a good option for meta
themselves in the meantime while the
facial expression technology may be a
cool feature for gamers and it's by no
means a selling feature or something
that people truly appreciate that would
be like buying an iPhone just for its
Emoji capabilities so this is simply yet
another example of meta chasing after a
currently non-existent Market instead of
giving the existing VR Market what they
want
foreign
questions surrounding the metaverse is
quite simple why does it suck so much
despite meta pouring tens of billions
into it well it really just boils down
to two things meta has an extremely
bloated Workforce that was highly
inflating development costs and meta has
no understanding of the current VR
Market instead of tending to the
Enthusiast Market by creating something
truly phenomenal that everyone can
appreciate meta decided to spend all of
their resources chasing it after the
general public and Enterprises the
result is an underwhelming product that
serves no one and is the laughing stock
of the internet with a customer
acquisition cost of 31.6 million dollars
and if meta doesn't change their focus
to address the current VR Market the
economics of the metaverse will remain
baffling for years to come do you think
that the metaverse will ever succeed
comment that down below also drop a like
if you wish that meta would spend some
of that money on collecting less data
instead of burning it on the metaverse
and of course consider checking out our
Discord community so just for the video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions and logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one